hi eric singer again dialect coach i'm
doing a map tour of north american
accents
if you missed part one check it out here
i'm starting part two from the south
picking up where we left off we were
talking about rhodic accents where the r
sound is always pronounced in the piney
woods belt but
down in the southern part of louisiana
this is one of the few areas that's
still pretty reliably non-rhodic
even though many historically non-rhodic
areas of the south have gotten their
oils back
this one's hanging on this is also one
of the places in the south the
appalachians and ozarks or a few of the
others
some parts of texas will you still hear
a sound
words like which what where you also get
f for final th sounds here is in both
bath something i think is really
interesting is that there used to be a
non-rhodic pronunciation of nice words
in the south
so words like nice early work
used by black and white southerners
alike that was a kind of a diphthong
hey nice it's actually pretty similar to
that old-fashioned new york city
today toy street vowel sound you can
still hear it in some african-american
speakers in louisiana today
though it's mostly gone otherwise before
moving on let's circle back to florida
so megan can tell us about the cuban
spanish influence in miami
hello again this time i'm in miami the
latinx population in the u.s
is 18.5 percent of the population but
within that we're a very diverse group
of people
before we get into miami english i just
want to make it clear
that not every speaker of miami english
is latinx
not every latinx person in miami speaks
miami english
and the same goes for new york latino
english and the same will go for chicano
english in the southwest when we get
there
we are not a monolith and neither are
the varieties that we speak
and that's because these varieties are
influenced by different spanishes
so just like the english-speaking world
has different varieties so does the
spanish-speaking world
there's so many different varieties of
spanish there's mexican spanish there's
cuban spanish there's puerto rican
spanish
there's dominican spanish there's all
these other spanishes
there are all these varieties and they
all have different features and we just
don't have time to get into that
miami english is influenced by cuban
spanish like take a look at this map
cuba is very close to miami one
remarkable feature of miami english is
the dark
l if you recall from new york the dark l
is in words like pole and ball in miami
english you'll hear that dark l
in places where you wouldn't hear it in
other varieties listen to the l in this
native speaker clip
that's what i love about our language
language language and about miami
okay back to eric thank you megan okay
back to louisiana so there's a
well-known new orleans accent that
sounds similar to new york accents in
some ways
it's called yat which comes from the
phrase where y'at
which means how are you it's so similar
to new york accents in some ways
it's a bit of a mystery even some really
weird little things
like bad and back not having the same
vowel sound
i got a bad back new orleans
had a similar mix of immigration to new
york in the 19th century
but also very close shipping ties to new
york city so
contact is likely part of the
explanation too
of course we can't leave louisiana
without talking about cajun
the cajuns were a french-speaking people
originally came down to louisiana from
nova scotia some still speak cajun
french but you can hear the influence
french had on cajun accents in english
in the rhythm and the melody the way it
has a tendency to stress the final word
or syllable in a phrase
and also in the way final consonant
sounds can get assimilated
sort of shlooped up into the sound
before them so that
hand could just be hang rent can just be
rent
hemi during there so continuing west to
texas
now one thing that sets a lot of texans
apart from other southerners
is that there's a lot less goose
fronting so the tongue stays further
back through that whole vowel
sound instead of coming forwards so if i
go from
say somewhere in the carolinas and head
west and talk about
blue moons and soup spoons i'll start
off with very fronted goose valves
blue moons and soup spoons but they'll
get less and less fronted
the further west i go blue moons and
soup spoons
blue moons and soup spoons when i cross
the mississippi i don't have very
fronted gooseballs anymore
but by the time i'm in texas blue moons
and soup spoons
it's not coming forward hardly at all
now now one thing that separates the
eastern part of the state from the
western part
is how far the price smoothing goes
remember when we talked about how
piney woods baled accents have full-on
price
smoothing so it affects ride and right
live and life we'll see that kind of
full-on version in western and central
texas
all those words are smoothed out just
like that but in the eastern part
it's only on words like high ride and
live
words like right and life will have a
diphthong why is it this way
well again because of the history of
settlement patterns
the white people who settled in the
western part in the great plains part of
texas the western and central
parts mostly came from tennessee and the
appalachians
full price smoothing areas as we head up
into oklahoma
i'm going to turn it over to kalina
newmark again hello again
oklahoma is a home to nearly 40 native
american nations including the cherokee
and the comanche
before jumping into the local native
american dialect features here in
oklahoma
i'm going to share a little bit about
the history of native american english
native american english is also known as
a res accent a reservation accent
it occurs in first nations and native
american communities
across the united states and canada
regardless of whether or not a heritage
language is spoken
native american english is often
identifiable because of its prosity
sometimes it's described as monotone
other times it's described as sing-songy
within oklahoma community members
describe native american english both
ways
and that makes sense there are different
varieties within the state
in western oklahoma the anadarko accent
has been described as monotone
contrast that with cherokee english in
eastern oklahoma
which is more sing-songy sometimes we
can forget where we come from you know
what
with that let's go back to eric on the
map tour thank you kalina
quick stop in the ozarks where we can
hear some accents that are real close to
southern appalachian accents
a little bit different goat val and some
others but real close in a lot of ways
which is because again of settlement
patterns the original european settlers
of the ozarks came from southern
appalachia
and we hear some of those same
constructions like a going and a hunting
as well as a lot of shared specific
dialect words
now up in chicago and in fact in the
whole great lakes area
we have one of the most significant
ongoing changes happening anywhere in
the english-speaking world today
it's called the northern cities shift or
the northern cities vowel shift
and it may be the biggest change in
english pronunciation anywhere since the
great vowel shift
right up to and through shakespeare's
time now it's a change shift
which is kind of a merry-go-round of
changes
here's how it goes so in most accents of
english the vowel sound
in words like uh cat bag what we call
the trap vowel
is something like ah right we make it
with the tongue
cupped down low and towards the front of
the mouth like this
ah okay ready for this here's the first
move
in the northern cities chain shift this
vowel unit
moves up in this direction so
it's pronounced with a little bit tenser
tongue and sounds like
cat bag up here put the cat in the bag
now that leaves an open space in terms
of available vowel real estate
where that trap vowel used to be now it
turns out that vowel sounds like to
space themselves out in their mouths
they abhor a vowel vacuum if you will
and so what happens is that the lot
vowel
which you know normally lives back here
your tongue cupping low down in the back
for an open
ah sound moves forwards
towards where trap used to be so in
chicago it's not a hot pot
it's a hat pat now those are just the
first two moves
in the chain shift the thing about a
chain shift is each move makes the next
one happen
so trap moving up higher
pushes the dress vowel back in the mouth
so words like bed next sound like
bud next and then the vowel sound that
was back there to begin with the ah
sound and strut bus
lucky has to move back further boss
lucky so now cot sounds like cat
bat sounds like bat bet sounds like butt
and butt
sounds like bought pretty dramatic shift
this whole area around the great lakes
is affected by the northern cities shift
though not every part of it has it to
the same extent beside chicago it's
strongest in syracuse rochester buffalo
and detroit
let's head over to saint louis here's
nicole there's a feature in
african-american english in places like
st
louis and memphis called the near square
nurse merger
or our centralization if you know the
song by the rapper nelly
hot and her you have seen an example of
this it is
her for here or our essentialization
and you can also hear it in this clip
girl i told you i need to get my hair
done
her done her done okay let's go back to
eric
thank you nicole can we talk about
minnesota for a minute
you know people from minnesota often
complain about
overbroad stereotypical minnesota
accents just going too far
two really identifiable features of that
are
monothongle a and o in your face
and goat vowels but you know there are
definitely places in minnesota michigan
wisconsin and
yep fargo north dakota where you can
still hear some pretty pronounced
accents
with some really monophthong a and o
vowels
now but even in much less pronounced
accents from this region
there will still be a bit of that you'll
also still get this fairly closed oral
posture so
there's a contrast between lips that are
pretty mobile and move around a lot and
a jaw that stays pretty fixed in place
now let's stop over in the dakotas and
i'll hand it off to kalina
hi again from the traditional homelands
of the lakota dakota and dakota peoples
continuing on our conversation at native
american english
i'm going to talk about two shared
features one timing and rhythm
and two intonation and pitch in regards
to timing and rhythm
native american english is syllable
timed where syllables are more uniform
and even in length
you can hear that feature in this clip
you see a piece of trash
you pick it up for the second feature
intonation and pitch
the stress syllable starts lower rather
than higher
and i would watch them in this clip from
the movie smoke signals
this actor is speaking in a native
american english accent
you can hear that on thomas here hey
thomas there are several theories of
where this dialect came from
one theory is that it developed because
of native american boarding schools
established in the late 19th and
mid-20th century
native american boarding schools were
designed to assimilate native american
children into white society
they did this by forcibly removing
native american children
from their families and communities and
forbidding them from speaking their
languages
at the time of european contact in north
america there were approximately 300
distinct indigenous languages
since then 113 of these languages have
been lost
and many more are in danger as fewer and
fewer native american children are
learning our languages despite
all of this we have created a dialect of
english that is uniquely ours
a dialect that helps us to create and
recreate our identities as native
american people
let's go back to eric for the next stop
on the map tour
thank you kalina quick detour to iowa so
remember that online that runs through
new jersey where
above it most people say on rhymes with
dawn and south of it most people say on
rhymes with dawn
and it runs right along a really major
dialect boundary between the north
linguistically speaking and the midlands
and it runs through all of these states
and through iowa too now people don't
necessarily think of iowa having a lot
of dialect variety but
here's a major division right here so
sioux city and cedar rapids are above
the online
so most people in those places say on
and des moines is below it
so most people there will say on all
right so heading west now
over towards the rockies you know one of
the things we start to hear in the
mountain west generally is ing endings
pronounced as
in so playing going singing
the whole western part of the country so
these 11 states
is usually considered one big dialect
area now that's not to say that there
aren't any differences of course there
are but
broadly speaking it's one area with a
lot of common features there just
hasn't been enough time for really
distinctive features to develop over
here
here's something interesting in some
utah accents though some front vowels
get lowered before
l sounds so we get milk for instance
the word sail might sound like cell
is this milk on cell you'll also hear
mount in
and but in mountain and button a lot in
utah
especially among younger speakers with
just a pure glottal stop
for that t sound in the middle of the
word it's not the only place in the u.s
that does that
not at all but apart from some
california speakers it seems to be the
only place in the west where you hear
those pronunciations
we're going to end this segment here
please join us for part three
where we'll pick up in sunny southern
california
you